when Amazon moves into a new line of
business its rivals tend to panic one by
one changing books toys clothing and
sports goods have disappeared as
Amazon's everything store offers cheaper
online alternatives Amazon can cost
companies billions of dollars in lost
market value last year inspectors spoke
more about Jeff bees with his company
than any other during calls with their
investors since Amazon was founded in
1994 is transformed for a money-losing
internet bookstore to a profitable mega
conglomerate with revenues of 233
billion dollars last year profits
arising to last year
Amazon's EBIT doll margin was a record
12% the company is still expanding in
the past three years and has purchased
online pharmacy full pack Supermarket
Whole Foods and a home security maker
blink how much bigger could it become
the FDA's Lex team examined five fears
surrounding Amazon and asks when they
are prescient
or paranoid fear first Amazon will
conquer the world
amazon is expanding into new businesses
and ramping up plans to sell more
products under its own brand in the u.s.
it accounts for 49 percent of online
sales but elsewhere Amazon faces fierce
competition international revenue makes
up only one quarter of the total earlier
this year Amazon announced that it was
closing its local e-commerce business in
China across Asia the 10-cent Softbank
industrial complex is winning
probability racing two out of ten
fear the second Amazon will replace
banks between 2011 and 2017 amazon says
that it loaned more than three billion
dollars to its own vendors but the
business remains secretive and has not
been offered more broadly to consumers
Amazon relies heavily on its own data
and lacks credit history information
that would help it take on banks
suggesting it will remain a mission
alone facility for ability rating of 3
out of 10 feared third Amazon will
deliver your customers lunch Alison's
acquisition of Whole Foods was its
biggest to date and it is investing
heavily in logistics but it has a mixed
record in delivering fresh products
grocery service Amazon fresh failed
revolutionize food distribution and it
recently shut its restaurant delivery
service in the u.s. online grocery
market sales account for just 5 percent
of the 700 billion dollar market to take
on a retailer like Walmart Amazon will
need many more physical stores
probability rating out of 10 steer the
4th Amazon or Fogg data
Amazon Web Services dominates the cloud
services market and is the company's
most profitable business Amazon has
helped companies store and process data
far more efficiently by moving it to AWS
servers but rivals like Google and
Microsoft are trying to expand their own
offers of Internet connected public
cloud services the cloud wars are just
getting started
probability racing won six out of ten
favorite Lee
Amazon will play doctors the US
healthcare system is right to worry
about
Amazon's interest in the 450 billion
dollars that Americans spend on
prescription drugs each year last year
Amazon bought online pharmacy pill pack
and is also working at Berkshire
Hathaway and JP Morgan on a joint
healthcare venture the Setzer is
notoriously complex and highly regulated
but Amazon is better placed to offer
online distribution than any pharmacy
chain probability rating 8 out of 10
Amazon is already one of the world's
biggest companies it accounts for 50
cents in every daily spent online in the
US and it hit a one trillion dollar
market capitalization more quickly than
Apple world domination will be stymied
by tech giants from Asia but Alison's
wide-ranging interests and fondness for
experimentation mean the next trillion
dollars is likely to come for healthcare
advertising AI is online shopping
[Music]